hello everyone after 1972 Bobby Fisher
didn't really play any more chess and
well there are very few published games
after 1972 that Bobby Fischer played he
did have that match a rematch against
Boris Spassky in 1992 but rather than
that not really and this is a match
played between Fischer and the
Greenblatt computer I was played in 1977
so five years after Bobby became world
champion and Fisher sent three of the
games he played against the Greenblatt
computer to be published and well in all
three games he crushed to the computer
later it was said that the computer was
rated around 2100 and Fisher claimed
that he could without without a problem
give odds to the computer so let's see
this is this is Game one and Fischer is
playing with the white pieces Fischer
groves efore and the Greenblatt computer
replies 'if I've we have F for the
King's gambit he captures on f4 and
Fischer plays Bishop to c4 the bishops
gambit of the Kings gambit and the
Fischer said that well probably the
computer would have played Queen to h4
check but it didn't it played the d5 and
so Fischer said that it obviously did
have some opening theory pre-installed
in the program so Fischer played Bishop
captures on d5 and now Knight to f6
attacking the bishop and e4 pawn Knight
to c3 and we have Bishop to b4 and
Knight to f3 green block computer
castles and Fischer also castles and we
have knife capture Sun d5 Knight captors
on d5 now Fischer is attacking this
Bishop on b4 and we have Bishop to d6
and d4 and well as you can see Fischer
has pretty much everything white white
would hope for when playing the Kings
gambit he has both of his central pawns
he's prepared to push
'if I've to grab the f4 pawn and well
all is well for Fischer and well here
here the computer had a couple of
options
it could have played Knight to c6 maybe
Bishop to g4 rook e8 is an idea but if
it played g5 which allows the Fischer a
nice tactic official plays Knight get
first
five Queen Catherine g5 and now each
five now blocking this bishops defense
of this f4 pawn
so here the computer doesn't retreat
with the bishop it plays Bishop to h3
now threatening checkmate and g2 so
Fisher defends this rope to F 2 and we
have Bishop to e5 Bishop captures pawn
on e5 and why didn't the computer try to
try to save his extra piece well it that
would have been a big blunder actually
if Bishop to e7 then Bishop captures on
f4 by Fischer and after the Queen moves
g3 and the Queen can no longer keep an
eye on this Bishop on e7 so after Queen
to g4 you get Knight captures on e7 with
check King to h8 and now Bishop to h6
and after the exchange of Queens Queen
after sandy one rook capture Sundy one
there is no way to defend the rook on f8
because if the rook moves you get rook
captures on f7 and now Fischer would be
threatening checkmate here on g7 so the
rock would have to go back through g8
and now still the Bishop to g7 check and
after rook captures rook to f8 check
rook g8 and rook captures and g8
checkmate so computer didn't really have
have a hard time calculating this so
after this rook to f2 it didn't try to
save the bishop it played Bishop
captures on e5
we have D captures on e5 and now c6
trying to get rid of that night but
Fisher of course first place Bishop
captures on f4 we have Queen to g7 and
now Knight to f6 check I only move if
you don't want to lose the Queen is king
to h8 and now Fischer plays Queen to h5
what with a lot of ideas Bishop to h6 is
an idea capturing the bishop on h3 is an
idea and the defending the bishop isn't
really possible if you move the Bishop
Bishop to e6
you get a bishop to h6 and now the Queen
can no longer defend the rook on f8 so
after just wing to h5 move green block
computer plays rook to d8 we have Queen
- Queen captures on h3 now Fischer is up
a piece as the these were the golden
days when you could play against the
computer and be up a piece
something unimaginable today when you're
playing against an engine we have
Knights to a6 and rook to f3 Fischer is
preparing rook to g3 so Queen to g6 now
eyeing this c2 pawn and well rub the g3
is a winning here
I mean this is crushing for white but
Fischer I guess he wants to make fun of
the computer he plays rook the c1 as
kind of defending the c2 pawn but
actually what Fischer did is he cut off
every square for the black Queen there
is no more squares for the black Queen
as Rob g3 is coming and while Queen is
covering at five Knight is covering
efore and now this point is covering d3
so the computer didn't really have a
resign button installed so the computer
played King to g7 we have rocked the g3
now the Queen is pinned rock to h8 and
Fischer place a queen to h6 with with
checkmate as at the king cannot capture
the Queen is defended by the bishop and
the Queen cannot capture the Queen as
the Queen's pin from the rook and g3 and
Fischer said that although it wasn't a
very Fischer said that it was a weak
computer that it could give it a great
odds and still win but Fischer said that
the greatest thing about playing this
computer is that it didn't resign it
allowed Fischer to to execute his
checkmate idea so yeah this is the game
there are two more games Fischer played
against the Greenblatt computer if you
enjoyed this game may be posted to the
other two so yeah that's it for this
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank roll the Silva and
Alexander Haig all for a contribution to
my channel I really appreciate it thank
you and yeah as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I'll see you soon